(upbeat music)
- But I'm goin' to the Goodwill first.
Thank you, sir.
You know what time it is.
(upbeat music)
What am I doing?
What do you think I'm doin'?
I'm tryin' to make some money.
(upbeat rock music)
Hey, wait a minute, this is Starbucks?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Get the fuck outta here, is it?
Tea rock.
What's up, everybody?
I'm mug lifin' on this WeeklyVee six.
If you do not love losing, you lost.
♪ I feel I can't lose ♪
♪ I'm mortal ♪
♪ Immortal, immortal ♪
(electronic music)
- WeeklyVee, what's up?
Monday was basically completely
confidential meeting day,
so that's what's going on on the vlog.
♪ Let's catch trains ♪
♪ Now it's planes flyin' ♪
♪ Now I'm real estate and
diamond chain buyin' ♪
♪ I used to count change ♪
♪ Now it's eight-figure deals ♪
♪ And I spent about a
million on the wheels ♪
♪ I can't believe what I've achieved ♪
♪ I can, but damn, I need a minute ♪
♪ It's hittin' me way differently ♪
♪ This is the dream, I need a minute ♪
- Heading home, super productive day.
Just got a ton done, just got
out of the leadership meeting
to wrap it up.
Just feeling very operational, very CEO-y.
A lot happened to beat our next level.
Never felt better.
Post three Super Bowl
spots, post tons of digital,
social, creative media AOR
work that's driving business.
Feeling it.
Hey guys, it's WeeklyVee Tuesday.
It's 10:44am.
I've had a big Vayner sports meeting.
Just did a podcast with the
founder of one of my investments
and now I'm going through
lots of headaches in my text.
(gentle upbeat music)
- Hey, everyone, I'm Nick.
I'm the head of education
at the Sasha group.
I am that character that sits
in the back right of the room
on the side of Gary during
all these 4Ds episodes
that everybody seems to love so much.
We're gonna watch a clip right now
from our most recent session.
It was actually the first one of 2020
that we held out of our
New York City Office.
These are just loaded with
tidbits of information
and obviously a lot of energy from Gary.
But for us, these are so much
fun because we get to work
right alongside with small
and mid market businesses
and really consult them in a full day
not just on their businesses,
but the way that this
whole machine thinks.
So enjoy this episode.
- [Man] Besides that
we've done some of this CR
like (mumbles) optimization.
But you're also getting
some traffic out there.
But the competition is too high.
There's lot of competitors--
- The biggest, it was similar
to what I was saying to him.
The biggest decision
you're gonna have to make
in the short term is you're
gonna have to transition
to brand marketing.
That's smart.
Versus what your, all
your energy is right now,
which is transactional marketing, right?
'Cause it is intent-based marketing
on Google search Ads, right?
I need a house cleaner
in Long Island, Enter.
You show up, cool.
I wanna outbeat you.
When I was doing it for wine
for five cents a click, good.
Now those same words are
eight bucks, not as good.
Less people even going to search.
Most people deciding to buy
wine 'cause of Instagram
and because Tick-Tok
and because of YouTube
and because of Podcast.
Couple of things.
One, not open yet.
But as for all of you, I
think one of the really good
ad products that's on
the verge of coming out
is a pre-roll live read,
meaning a human reads it,
Spotify product that's gonna be out
in about three to six months
where you'll be able to
like you buy Google AdWords,
and Facebook ads, put in a script
that you want podcast readers to read.
And then you pay for the impressions
and people just read them,
like podcast providers, makers, right?
Negotiation ninjas can
decide to be a part of this.
And when he starts his podcast, he goes,
"Ricky's donuts now available."
And like literally live read
old school 1950s radio at scale.
I think that's gonna be interesting.
And you can run it in
New York and Miami only.
I think your business explodes
if you figure out how to
do Facebook marketing.
'Cause Facebook, is the killer
app for 45 to nine year olds,
which I already liked from
a residential standpoint
of having the network to be
able to afford a house cleaner
instead of not right, instead
of doing it your fucking self.
And when you really
understand Facebook Ads
and really understand how to break down
New York and Miami into 45 to
50, different segmentations
and then what video or picture
to put in front of them
and really get good at it,
Facebook will return so much more for you
than Google AdWords long term
and will build brand equity
and creates word of mouth in
a way that Google doesn't.
Google, I type in, I need a
house cleaner in Rochester.
Enter.
It's insular.
Facebook, if you make a
really interesting ad,
I may share it, or I tag Mary Belle in it.
It's inherently word of mouth structured,
not transactional structured,
which is why it's so much more powerful.
(upbeat music)
- What's up, everybody?
Hello Caleb.
This is Tyler here.
My new title is office of the CEO,
formerly Nate's title but
now Nate works for him
if he wants.
Nate's over there in the cut.
We're about to go into a clip
that is really Gary speaking
for about five minutes
and the clip was five minutes 30 seconds
about sports cards with Serge Ibaka.
It's been fascinating,
the sports card saying
as someone that's ever
worked with Gary six years
and really known him well for five years
and watched his cycle of
where he's deploying capital
and resources from an investment strategy.
So listen here to this clip,
where Gary's pushing Serge
Ibaka to get involved
as well from an investment standpoint,
from a cultural relevance standpoint,
and I charge you to yourself
as well just pay attention.
Go to eBay,
Search PSA-10 prism, PSA 10 and go to Sold
and just see how much
is being actually sold.
The two highest items on eBay last year
sold were both trading cards.
And so it's been wild to see
Carrie does close to zero
now, startup investing,
and his returns on sports cards
and my returns personally
have been phenomenal.
And I charge you to actually
listen to what he's saying.
And go make a play.
That's what we call it.
Make a play.
- You know what you should do?
You should start
investing in sports cards.
- Sports cards?
- I'm not kidding.
Listen to me.
I'm telling you, no bullshit.
I made $150,000 on LeBron James
rookie cards in four months.
They've gone from $1,000 to $4,000.
CJ McCollum texted me today.
- Yeah.
- He's made $200,000 in a month.
Listen, I'm being dead serious.
I've put over a million
dollars in sports cards
over startups and over real estate.
And how much did we
make on Moon (mumbles)?
- Moon (mumbles), we made like 7X.
For the LeBron I mean,
I've just been getting into
a little bit like (mumbles)
I bought the LeBron
three weeks ago at $2400.
- [Both] It's 4000.
- If the Laker--
- LeBron maker?
- No, LeBron rookie.
- Your teammate, Siakam
last year before the run,
call it this time last year,
it's gone up 80X, 80X.
You could have spent 200,000 and made 80X.
I bought 800 Yohanes rookie
cards last year at $180
they are a $1,000.
I'm telling you right now.
It's like sneakers all the sneaker kids.
You can't get enough off-whites,
you can't get enough Travis Scott's,
you can't get enough Yeezy's
but if you're right about who
I bought a ton of for pennies?
Devante Graham, point guard in Charlotte.
Like if you know sports,
you could make a fortune.
And I mean, a lot.
- What is (mumbles)?
- Three things.
One, 45 year olds like me, the
biggest era of sports cards
was 1986 to 1992 ever.
80, those boys now have sons
that are six, seven, eight,
so that always happens.
That's how toys work every 20 years.
Number two, gambling.
Gambling.
You can buy a three now, a
pack of cards can be $200 now.
Yeah.
And you know what you can find in there?
$150,000.
(upbeat music)
You can pull $150,000 Luca
rookie card from last year
in a pack of cards.
Gambling.
Number three, sneakers.
You can't get enough of these.
If you know this is the next hot sneaker,
you can't buy enough dunks of white color.
You can't get enough.
It's over.
The internet, Limited Edition.
So what happened is all those
kids that made a ton of money
as 13, 14, 15, 16 year olds,
'cause they got all their
friends from high school
to stand in line at a sneaker store
and buy 50 pairs, that game's over.
So they've taken their
attention to sports cards.
Because if you were
right about Luka Doncic,
I bought Lukas for $38 last year,
because Draymond Green told
me he's like a real player.
And I trust him because he's Dray.
He's always like, fuck everybody.
He was like, this guy can play.
Now they're fucking $400.
I could have bought, I bought hundreds,
I could have bought 10,000.
I could have made fucking
millions of dollars.
You're gonna love this.
I think you can answer this.
'Cause I bought 61 of them the other day.
What's the one card
I'm buying the most of?
- I don't know.
- The number one card I'm
buying, I can't wait to tell you,
Hakeem Olajuwon rookie card.
It's $250.
Nothing.
My belief is that Africa
in the next 30-40 years
is gonna be the number one
new continent like Asia.
And when that happens,
Hakeem Olajuwon rookie cards
are gonna be the demand.
I mean, this is 30 years.
It's a long time, but I still believe it.
I'm buying so much Hakeem
Olajuwon, it's crazy.
Vision.
- This is aws.
- That's right.
But what's fun--
- Yeah, that's true.
- What's fun--
- To have a vision.
- So for you, whether it's
Jordan or Magic or Kareem, fine.
But then on top of that, so
there's our long term, 30 years.
And then there's,
and this why you have
such a big advantage,
there's Thursday night in Cleveland
and you're watching Collin Sexton
and you're like, why
has he gotten so good?
Right?
Like there's a two sided, there's high.
I mean, if you're right
about Colin Sexton,
if you're right about him, if
you're right about your guy,
Terrence, like you get those right,
you're talking 20, 50, 100X.
So you gamble a little here, and you buy.
But I'm telling you--
- You can't just--
- Ask him.
He watches what I do.
No investing 'cause
everything's overpriced
'cause everyone's got a start up.
- It's like I've seen the cycle of like,
I mean, you're not writing--
- Any checks.
Like you were wring $25,000 checks
like you were four or five years ago.
- Correct.
- When you say like, investment wise.
- So I'm gonna give you
the advice I'm taking.
I'm not investing anybody's startups
'cause it's all bullshit.
Everybody's got a business.
Everything's eight to $15 million.
Meanwhile, this is black and white
and I like it and know it.
(upbeat music)
Blog each Wednesday,
really interesting insight.
Yesterday in general with
no real obvious rationale,
I was in a little bit of a
less fired up optimistic mode.
I was definitely not pessimistic
and I'm not sure what content
we'll see from yesterday
and you might even be like,
what are you talking about?
But I could literally feel
it like I was at an 88
instead of where I am
right now, which is a 97
in the gratitude excitement thing.
I don't know if I fasted
for almost two days,
so maybe my energy was a little bit down.
I eat too much over the weekend.
I'm trying to keep it tight.
You can see the dimples coming back.
You noticed I lost a lot of weight, Tess.
- [Man] It just seems (mumbles).
- Fair enough.
You see me every day,
but go look back at some December videos.
Nonetheless, just whether
it was the weather,
it's been gloomy.
There's a lot of rain lately.
It was sunny here today.
Because I really enjoy usually
I attribute that to meetings
that I'm not excited about:
firing someone, negatives
but I didn't really have that
in my schedule yesterday.
So it caught my attention.
So weekly update on Hump Day.
I'm so grateful that my
down or challenge days
are in the B range of
the school graph, B minus
but it feels really good
to be in a A plus, A minus,
A minus, A range today,
so happy about that.
I thought that was interesting to share.
I think my range is tighter on happy.
But I do think even within my range,
you can feel a B minus.
That's my range.
An I have family members,
friends, deep relationships
that range between A and
F and that's challenging
and I have a lot of empathy,
compassion, sympathy for that.
My big thing is not beating yourself up
or getting too down on
when it's not clicking.
I think people perpetuate
things where it's like,
oh crap, today's a bad day,
and it just becomes like,
you spin out of hands like,
it was interesting.
I kept it in the pocket of
like tomorrow's in play.
And sure enough, but that
I forced that through
that perspective or whether
it's just the serendipity
of my normal state like,
I'm just in an even higher, elevated mood.
Actually know what's
funny, just look the Tyler.
There was something
that happened yesterday
with one of our great
employees that was challenging,
and I wonder if that was
right in the morning.
I wonder if that put me in
a subconscious sad state.
So (chuckles) he's like,
what are you talking about?
So anyway, good stuff.
Hope you're getting
value out of the block.
- [Man] I appreciate you doing that.
Because sometimes I think
you're not human and I think
that really shows that you are.
- Yeah, I think that's right.
I'm trying to and even the way I put it
'cause I wanna tell the truth.
Somebody who's watching
right now and is like,
B minus, fuck you dick.
I'm a deep.
But I am trying to push myself
to be a little bit more vulnerable.
I'm a little bit worried that
the tension I have right now
bro, you know this, you're around me,
like this is showing in
the vlog I'm sure now
but you actually know this dude,
I am optimistic and grateful.
Like way, way, way more than the masses.
- [Man] That makes me think
that you're not human.
- Correct and I'm worried
about that in a lot of ways
because A, that, B, I don't
want people to aspire to that,
C, I don't want people
to become detached to me
or resentful at me for it.
I'm trying to find a way
to make it bring value,
not perpetuate frustration.
So I think it's imperative on me to evolve
in doing the best I can,
even though it's not my natural state
because showing vulnerability
bleeds into complaining,
which is something I'm visceral to.
So I'm trying to challenge myself as well.
And like even you responding that way,
gives me the affirmation of like, exactly.
Knowing that you can swim more than me.
And so can literally fucking
99% of everybody else
who's watching this right this second.
And knowing that out of all
the other stuff in the vlog
this week, this two minute 13 second clip,
has the potential help one fucking person
for real seriously.
And I think the biggest insight
was don't beat yourself up.
Like I could see that yesterday's B minus,
or whatever the fuck
it is with my arbitrary
could have led to C minus today
if I let it and I understand that.
And that's the insight.
Don't beat yourself up.
Don't.
It's like a sports mentality.
Go over eight to this four
over four over four baseball
like cool, you know three over
three in the two home runs.
And like you have your
life in front of you.
That's what leads to so much happiness.
You'd be 37, watching this.
Right now, everything you have 60 years.
Everything.
Like sports, you losing 21 to
Chiefs won a Super Bowl show.
They were down by double
digits in every game.
Real talk.
(hip hop music)
- Hey, guys, this is Mike
Boyd from Monday to Monday
and what you're about to
watch is a meeting we had
with Russ in Atlanta in the studio.
Check it out.
- No, but you were saying like--
- This is one of the
fewest humans on Earth
that I'm like, you can say it, right?
It's very rare.
It's why I knew you were gonna be human.
Bro, bro, you were gonna be so much bigger
than you are right now
because you're a starter Tick-Tok account.
(all laughing)
No, but on some real shit, honestly,
the reason that fucking song
when that moment happened
it was about like, eight weeks ago?
- Yeah, October 18th.
- Beautiful.
When I saw that, I swear to God,
I was like, you have
like 15 more of those.
- I know.
- Well, and honestly, you know what?
- What we're talking about though
is that every, you never stop blowing up.
It's an ongoing--
- If you're great enough.
(both talking over each other)
- That has already been ingrained.
- We didn't see what Elton
John's career looked like
in the beginning.
We're too young.
- Right.
You watched Eminem's freestyle
videos when he was 17
in his house or whatever?
No, but the video that
that I'm referring to,
you were saying aggressiveness.
You don't understand it
and y'all hear the energy
but not the words.
- 100%
(both talking over each other)
- Yo, yo, yo, what's good?
- If you do not listen to this man's music
every fucking night, you're fucking up.
I'll keep it real simple.
Russ tell 'em something important.
- Well, I'll tell you
what's very important
is that Gary's always ahead of the curve.
And once again this is
something that I champion
is the fearlessness to be down.
To be like yeah, I'm just y'all are here.
Come on over here.
You know what I'm saying?
And that fearlessness is
like it's a quality that
even if you don't like what
he's being fearless about,
it's a quality that if you had more of it
maybe you could be (mumbles).
You're down to go down.
- Die on your own fucking sword.
It's as simple as that.
♪ Call my phone ♪
♪ I don't wanna text you anymore ♪
♪ I just wanna stop this civil war ♪
♪ Baby please ♪
- Give me two seconds.
- You're saying you wanna
see what it looks like
and you care about others.
People care about lifting weights
and then it's basically
this cake was after.
(bright music)
- Wow.
The land of make-believe.
- So I'm thinking you
started first two seconds.
I wanna see what it looks
like when other people think,
if you wanna see what it looks.
- I actually hear something.
So you don't have to act as
me 'cause I know what it is.
(Andy laughing)
You tell me what I need to say.
- You don't wanna do that.
When you wake up, do
you think other people
care about your problems?
Or when you--
- I wanna see what it looks
like when you stop caring
about other people's opinions.
- You wanna see what it looks
like when you think people
care about your complaints.
You wanna see what it looks like when.
'Cause you're saying, well,
we're in the land of make believe.
So people thinking that they
actually care about complaints
is make believe.
- I see.
Tick tock, I wanna see what it looks like
when you think you're
gonna be a millionaire
by the time you're 25.
- Right.
- Real quick, real quick.
- Do another one.
- I actually have a three part to this.
It's that, this and I wanna finish it.
- [Andy] Yeah, I wanna get finished quick.
- That doesn't mean you can't,
it just means that most
people don't realize
the amount of time and work that it takes
to actually get there.
I have a feeling that that can
be a really consistent thing
for me, because I think
most people live in
don't believe all the time.
So I think we can do that a lot.
Let's see how this does.
Everything's make believe.
- Yeah.
- I think almost everything
everybody believes is wrong.
- It's a trend where where
people drop like glitter
and whatnot on their phone.
It goes in slow mo when you pick it up.
- So smart.
Oh, that's nice.
It has the potential intro to maybe five.
I'll have you drop it and
then you can just turn to me.
- Right, so I'm gonna do
the thing you need to do
to add on to it.
- [Jason] Then you can
be like, this is weird.
- Wait, how did you get it on?
- [Jason] You ready?
- And you want me to, I
can look down at your phone
or look at you?
- Yeah.
You can look down at it
and then you can turn to me afterwards.
And this is WeeklyVee 5.
- Cool.
- Awesome.
(all talking over each other)
- The best part is, and this
is the funny part about me
is I weirdly like to
eat food off the floor.
Like, I'm not weirded out by it.
(upbeat music)
- DJ Will.
- Such a pleasure.
- It's a pleasure, man.
- How are you, my man?
It's a real pleasure.
It's ridiculous, DJ Mr. Famous.
- It's a real pleasure.
I salute you.
Hello.
- Hi.
I'm Natashee.
- Natashee, how are you?
- Good.
- Good, what's good everyone?
We parented and grandparented by people
who didn't live to 100.
But we are.
So that's the shit I'm trying
to get people to think about.
How old are you?
- 30.
- Right.
So like when we were fucking
18, 43 seemed like 1000.
(all laughing)
And now we're like, I don't know,
I feel like I got my
whole life in front of me.
- Yeah.
- Obviously, we've been through some shit.
There's a lot to do.
- Not for me!
I started feeling last
couple years (mumbles).
Is this it?
- You know what ends up
happening in your game
is when you're in something
that has youth culture in it,
you see somebody doing something special
that you're proud of for
them or happy for them
or envious of them and they're 19.
You're like, damn.
My own thing is like, don't look at them
look at the other 4 billion
people that 80 doing shit.
Everybody was like, but Gary
look at Mark Zuckerberg,
he is 25.
Or look at fucking Chance
the Rapper, he already did.
I'm like, what about the
fucking trillion fucking people
that are 80 doing shit and
still haven't broke through?
Why are you looking at the 0.000000001%
to judge your happiness?
Why don't we look at the fucking masses?
Us sitting in this room.
Us being in America.
We're ready winning.
Perspective.
And once you see
gratitude and opportunity,
like it's fun.
When you think something's
suppressing you,
it's easier for you to
feel suppressed, minority
all of that, I get it.
That's true.
That's actually true.
But once you get into
what am I gonna look at?
A lot of things are true.
What was true for me was
I spent the first 20 years
building my parents business for them.
That was my truth.
Like, lots of things are true.
(gentle upbeat music)
Nobody's life was good.
Men have tragic ends, like
there's a lot of truth.
You get to decide if you're gona dwell
and play prevent-defense,
or if you're gonna see
opportunity and be grateful
and go on offense.
That's what I'm trying
to get people through.
I could sit with anybody,
show me the richest white male in America,
and he'll cry about some shit
like his mom was horrible.
You know what I mean?
Like you pick.
- Everybody has a story.
- And then everybody knows somebody
who's got all sorts of
fucked up situations,
and they're happy.
That's called perspective.
I know.
Everybody can talk about
somebody who's happier than them
that has it way worse,
and sadder than them that
has it way better, right?
And if that's true,
which it is for everybody you think,
then that becomes the actual game.
That's what I think about.
And that's what I'm
trying to make popular.
And that's why I think
it's making an impact.
Because it leads to a
nice place, you know?
Yeah, because, I come from
a place that's more zero.
And the way I talk to people in that spot
is not looking down at them,
and it's not even trying to inspire them.
It's just real.
Everything I just said
sounds inspirational,
it's actually practical.
It's not rah rah shit like you can do it.
It's how are you choosing
to look at your life?
And then if you practically
realize opportunity,
and be grateful for
whatever the fuck you have,
'cause somebody's always got it worse,
well then it could start
getting interesting.
(gentle upbeat music)
I think every set like,
so I'm listening to,
and I'm like, yep, yep.
And I can like chip on
shoulder, chip on shoulder
in the right, he's right.
Is the punch line.
Miley Cyrus twerking on MTV
Music Awards six years ago,
is a lame Instagram post.
Below average.
You wouldn't even stop in your feed shit.
That's what he meant.
My man, Jamal Adams everyday
does something 2x what he did.
He's right.
Culture moves.
I think the game now is
how to muscle memory.
He was in the storm so
he had to adjust, right?
Fucking like adjust.
Like there's a lot that happens with that.
He changed consciously and subconsciously.
He knows it's true so that sucks
'cause he's right, he didn't do shit.
He entertained, right?
But I look at it as,
that's what happens a lot
in this scenario is like,
it's kind of like Hall of Famers
that made less money than
a bench player now makes.
Then you got their Matt.
I talk to Hall of Famers all the time.
70 year olds who are like,
these motherfuck, fucking right?
I had a fucking job in the off-season.
This motherfucker can't shoot
and he's gonna make more
this year than I made in my career.
And I'm like, stop, flip it.
You're playing prevent defense.
You know how many
touchdowns this man scored
on prevent defense?
You go prevent defense.
Yeah, and?
Fuck it, now let's go legend shit.
Let's go sign a million
basketballs, let's make new content.
It's turning bitter chip
on shoulder, fuck all that,
all that energy into fuck
it, I'm gon' own this shit.
I'm the OG.
Every time somebody does
something, you're like, good.
You just turn it.
I don't know how else to say it.
You take the circumstances
of your life and you turn it
from prevent defense
to 100% run and shoot.
And that's easy for us
to say he was in it.
But all my friends who
like him, I pound them.
Because what's the alternative?
'Cause you got nothing but opportunity
because all that shit led to
the fact that I'm sitting here
and wanna have this convo
because you have the platform
to do anything you want.
But it's once you change that angle
that you look at it from,
that's when all the fucking magic happens.
(bright music)
Now, I don't know if you saw the news,
but it just popped up on TMZ right here
$900,000 for the LeBron
Jordan, one of one upper deck.
I'm telling you, the culture
of sports cards, you know.
First it was these.
First it was the kicks.
The kicks keep on coming.
Dads that have kids that
are seven, eight are coming.
And the gambling's coming.
(car honking)
You can put $1,000
in a pack of cards.
Sports card culture is here.
I've been trying to tell you.
It's gonna keep happening.
If you love sports betting,
if you love fantasy sports,
if you think you know
something about rookie,
if you wanna bet long
term and buy classics,
time is now.
The culture's happening.
Don't miss the fuck out.
(upbeat music)
I'm really excited about this.
I really think it's gonna be a big deal.
But back to being, if you
wanna be the mother sponsor.
You're like baby, everybody
has to have the app to get in.
I'm being real.
Like I want it to be
a business win for you
in a way that's like, real obvious.
♪ Guess what ♪
♪ I just put my logo in my pool ♪
♪ I just made porno in the booth ♪
♪ Guess what ♪
♪ They been takin' photos when I move ♪
♪ I still got control,
though how 'bout you ♪
♪ Guess what ♪
♪ I just put my logo in my pool ♪
- Dominating.
♪ They be takin' photos when I move ♪
♪ Guess what ♪
♪ I still got control,
though, how 'bout you ♪
♪ Guess what ♪
♪ Race against your doubt ♪
♪ A lot of y'all ain't
runnin' fast enough ♪
♪ I can spot a fake before
we even finish dappin' up ♪
♪ Clappin' when they win ♪
♪ But when I win, they never clap it up ♪
♪ Parents marriage crumble
so I told my moomma ♪
♪ Pack it up ♪
♪ Eat until I'm fat enough ♪
- I saw.
- [Man] How'd you feel?
How you feel?
- Winning's winning.
I love it.
I really got hurt last year.
(both talking over each other)
It was some real shit.
I was out for four months.
Real high ankle sprain.
- One up here?
- I really caught it.
Inside.
- Boy, you needed some ankle shooters.
- You know what's funny?
I left it in the hotel room.
(both laughing)
You good?
- How're you doing, bro?
- You playing?
- Wait a minute--
- Let's go!
Let's go!
- I'm gonna hoop that.
- Good to see you, bro.
How you been?
- I've been great.
- Great to see you.
Who needs a dominating force?
- Winning five on this side.
- Who needs a dominating force?
(player laughing)
- I was watching with
that sort of a change,
clothes change like
Instagram of removing likes,
removing comments--
- Yeah, likes.
- And mask as a, to protect bullying.
- [Gary] Yep.
- But really, I think as
a sort of a mask sorting
is to sort of monetize what they're doing.
- Can sort of they're kind of taking cut.
- It's not that.
Let me tell you something that
everybody is so cynical about
and have not taken a thoughtful look at.
- [Moderator] It's not about bullying?
- It's not only about bullying,
it's much further than that.
And I spent a lot of time with this.
Like this will be maybe a
thing that you can take away
that you'll really find fascinating.
Just take a step back
and follow this logic.
The entire business model
of Facebook and Instagram,
Snapchat, Tick-Tok is for
you to stay on the platform.
Nothing else.
People are very naive to how much mon.
Some of the biggest banks in
the world have just pulled off
of Facebook because of an algorithm thing.
And they're asking me why Facebook
isn't just like doing something
and they're spending hundreds
of millions of dollars.
And I looked them in the face and said,
"'Cause you mean nothing to them.
"You have no leverage.
"You think you do."
We've talked about this with like the NFL.
This is not about influencers monetizing
because what you're referring to,
if he's an influencer and
there's not showing the likes,
the back end shows the likes
and he's more than welcome
to show it to Mountain
Dew and get his cut.
And if you're in a partnership program,
you see all the data.
This is strictly about
Facebook Inc., Instagram,
knowing that everybody's
so fucking insecure
that the numbers are dictating.
You know there are people don't post
the things they actually wanna post?
They're posting the things they
know will do well in likes.
Do you know how many women
I talk to that are pretty,
that are in stuck in
this fucking evil cycle
of having to show their bodies
to get the amount of likes
and not talk about the fact
they actually know fitness
or wine or food culture?
But if they post that, they get 48 likes
and if they post their tits and ass,
they get fucking 80 million
and they just can't get out of there.
They're like in pain
'cause they're like fucking
stuck in the machine.
I predict that fake
Instagram is gonna not only
take away likes, they are
gonna take away followers.
I think a lot about
the creation of a crew.
Like the same way garage sales.
If you have someone like,
oh, I got this new idea.
Youngsters like you.
You're set up in like shit
apartment in New York or LA.
What about creating a crew, further out,
so like weather it's (mumbles)
pay more than you know,
if you're an hour on the
train, you get a lot more.
It's 'cause you want the action.
You want the accessibility, the action.
But I've been thinking a
lot about like the crew.
Like you should find your adventures,
find your own other four players.
- And eat together.
You go out an hour out, you're
all training in the city
or driving in together,
in a crew together.
But, again you pull that money,
you're an hour out from
wherever the places
now you got a fucking pad where you cook.
A lot of people tend to be be creative.
So whether that's like now
all of you have way more room,
better join living room,
even another side room
where you guys can hang,
you can use it.
That could be the flipping room.
Like to me, like thinking right now
that could be with four
buddies who are hungry,
we're trying to make something happen.
And we have a flip room
where all of us crash out,
just throwing it in there
and that's an extra bedroom
because again, all our
bedrooms are bigger.
We have a living room.
I'm thinking a lot more about
like If I was like 20 years.
Like create a crew.
An hour out, but a crew.
Five roommates, but an hour out.
Because now two people inevitably
are getting on the train
the same time like to your normal job.
- [Tyler] Except you doing it alone,
it would be way more productive,
going back and forth.
- This is, look--
- Exactly.
- What's happening right now?
If all of us went into our
own cars, we could text.
But like there's something
about the bouncing
of this moment.
- Right.
- It led me to like first
finally taking the subconscious
and the conscious.
Irak whips out his phone, films it.
Now some kid sees it.
It's like, this is creative.
- Right.
(upbeat music)
- Before you wanna vlog,
basically wanna blog on Twitter daily,
because then I want
137 to take that video,
embed it into an article
and either you write out.
Like I really wanna do this.
I like volume.
I like hip hop at lunch.
2020, social media it out.
We can have three, I mean am I wrong?
There's two people a day
you could do that with.
- (mumbles) I can stack them up.
- Just live life.
Live life.
Like you saw something
you like, you're like,
oh I like this Rekocast.
DM, (mumbles).
Like you wanna be on Gary Vee's 147?
Yes.
Well we're going to Goodwill first.
- [Mike] Okay. (laughs)
- Thank you sir.
You know what time it is?
(upbeat music)
What am I doing?
What do you think I'm doing?
I'm trying to make some money.
(bright funky music)
What?
I've always done well without.
(funky upbeat music)
eBay up.
Not good.
$2.
(funky upbeat music)
Fucking 1982.
That shit pisses me off.
♪ Say you'll do it forever ♪
(funky upbeat music)
Love Life
Love life.
Paris.
Oh, wait a minute, this is Starbucks?
- Yeah.
- Get the fuck outta here.
Is it?
I don't think it is.
Tea rock.
CD rock.
Look at this live life.
Hit it,
hit it.
Guarantee.
This is a mug that's
worth more than 99 cents,
that's what I mean.
I guaranteed this is a winner.
Think I got one.
That's a good one.
Good job, do you rock?
I guarantee this Ritz Carlton.
Watch this.
Watch this C-rock.
Hit now the screen record.
It's gonna look cool actually.
10 bucks.
Let's go.
Fuckin' fuckers.
Oh my God!
I'm not buying it but I just...
I love that.
Boy it's like we're supposed
to see it in studio.
It's like literally not willing to leave.
(woman laughing)
Just literally.
(bright upbeat music)
By the way, I have a big innovation idea.
This is for you Apple.
In your alarms, there should be notes
because I set these random alerts.
And like if I add a note to
why I'm setting the alarm,
that would kill.
- [Man] It's called a reminder.
- Apple, good job.
(all laughing)
- [Man] And for me mainly it's--
- For you, you need to
monetize your voice.
(all laughing)
Like for you, no matter
what you're about to say,
you should quit working with
him and start a voice business
and be out.
Yeah, bro.
For you, that's that.
You like how on top of that I am, right?
I always love when D-Rock's in the gaps.
He hates when I know something he doesn't.
You like it for me.
You hate it for yourself.
You hate your life.
Get out of here, fucking D-Rock.
That's right, just one shot.
D-Rock.
- Oh! (laughs)
- Do it for the content.
If you look at this table right now,
there's literally bottles of water
that cost three fucking dollars.
I have no, will you buy Fiji?
Is that true?
Is it our bottles?
Like that's the stupidest
shit of all time.
We're literally paying.
Like it's water.
4% of your entire life.
70 times 20.
Yeah, forget about that.
Before anybody signs that.
- You ready?
You ready?
- Yeah, but I'm gonna, where is he?
In the studio?
Where is he, in there?
- Yes.
- Yes!
Yes I am.
I'm here.
Usually we gotta do this shit.
Where is it?
Yeah, what's good?
Live your fucking life!
Stop fucking bullshit!
(man laughing)
Get yours!
(bright upbeat music)